okay quick voicemail here from the
Eggman are our voicemail number is two
one nine to david p the Eggman called in
commenting about this if Bernie isn't
the nominee would you vote for Hillary
or Trump thing that we started talking
about last week here's what the egg man
had to say hey Dave regarding a
voicemail you said yesterday it was
awesome and a hundred percent dead on I
want Bernie Sanders but I want Trump
over Hillary Clinton because I feel he
is more progressive a lot of people
think that it's not a small minority
it's bigger than you think and I'll tell
you what as soon as Trump says I'm going
to legalize the marijuana on a national
level and reclassify it he's going to
get way more from Bernie Sanders
supporters behind slump when Sanders
doesn't get it because you know the
Democrats have it all set up for Hillary
so I'm telling you right now more people
think like that caller thinks and if
some sense anything about weed it's over
okay he's going to get a lot of votes
Hillary could have to do a lot of fixing
to win this election all that influence
that you've got shallow little brother
love you Lois big boy okay all right
yeah so I still think that this is
anecdotal I don't think in any large
numbers Bernie supporters are going to
vote for Trump Louis I I know that those
who would do it or getting very
boisterous now but I don't think it is
going to be statistically significant
probably not yeah but we're we're
hearing more of this from people and I
think it's interesting and I I think
that it's not without merit and so we'll
see what happens on the bonus show today
an incredible trash build up in Beirut
Lebanon I also have to just amazing
stories from over the weekend one
involving me being involved in a
political conversation I wanted nothing
to do with that went horribly wrong and
another story involving I'll just say it
involves a pedophile neighbor that's as
far as I'll go really interesting bonus
show today david pakman.com slash
membership to sign up don't miss it